dis-moi nièce tu as pas vu quasiment
aujourd'hui non tu sûr tu l'as pas vu
tiens à dire bonjour ça va je suis
content nous voir dites vous n'auriez
pas vu casimir aujourd'hui non halal à
cet ennuyeux je savais depuis qu'on lui
a fait des reproches sur sa peinture il
a disparu et sans lui le jardin vert
tout vide regarde le jardin alerte
triste tu sais que j'attends aussi le
retour de sabrina sabrina est parti se
renseigner dans la partie de l'île où
casimir vie avec le restant de sa
famille elle connaît très bien sa
famille la tante adélaïde de plus
intérêts d'une question qui pour lui
donner des renseignements sur l'endroit
où se trouve casimir l'instant les yeux
tu sais quand on fait des reproches à
quelqu'un il vient très souvent on se
rend pas compte de la peine qu'on peut
lui faire
sabrina alors tu as des nouvelles pas
grand chose sa tante adélaïde m'a dit
qu'elle avait vu partir hier soir avec
un grand carton et une valise depuis
personne ne l'a vu et il n'a pas dit où
ils allaient et les autres l'aller les
cousins et les cousins de théodule
onésime et l'oncle hiéroglyphes
ils savent pas où il aide écoute ne
t'énerve pas je te dis que j'ai cherché
le mieux possible sa famille ne sait
rien
jean sabrina alors bonjour ça va ce
matin
ben non justement c'est ça va pas très
fort facteur non ça va pas du tout
pourtant les raids ou c'est beau je suis
pas c'est un plaisir de vivre dans cette
île pas vrai l'airé du maintien c'est
vrai je t'avais même pas marqué mais
vous n'avez pas l'air votre assiette où
vous vous êtes malade j'ai pas vous avez
l'air de radis dont on a enlevé la peau
nous sommes très ennuyés factor vous
allez mauvaise mine
vous voulez que j'aille vous cherchez un
docteur mais non mais non ce pas la
peine ce pas la peine nommé simplement
sabrina et moi on est très inquiet
figurez-vous que casimir a disparu et
depuis hier soir on n'a pas vu un jeu
une heure à peine avec lui avec casimir
bon sur non enfin vous pouviez pas le
dire du tout mais vous ne m'a pas laissé
par les voyons et que vous êtes il dit
rien ah mais il m'a remis une lettre
pour vous donner une vie des 18 mètres
hélène vient bien s'il vient ici hélène
vient une lettre de casimir qu'est-ce
que ça peut bien être cher françois
scherr sabrina je pense que c'est la
dernière fois que vous entendrez parler
de moi je m'en vais je quitte lille aux
enfants pour chercher un pays où mon
talent de peintre sera enfin apprécier
je ne vous en veux pas mais je ne
pouvais plus supporter qu'on se moque de
moi pour rang casimir temps des tricks
j'espère que vous garderez un bon
souvenir de moi je pars à l'aventuré
la vie sera dur mais je préfère mourir
de faim et de soif dans un désert plein
de serpent que d'être considéré comme un
imbécile
nous ne l'avons jamais considéré comme
un investissement pour sûr
adieu dont ne m'oubliez pas casimir et
voilà c'est tout c'est ne plus jamais
voir casimir le gabon sable il faut
faire quelque chose là oui faire quelque
chose mais quoi nous manque tant que ça
oh oui facteurs donné si je le voyais
arriver maintenant je lui donnerai tous
les plus beaux jours de ma boutique au
tous ceux qui préfèrent une voiture de
pompiers une ambulance un voilier
rolala tous les jouets que je préfère et
moi facteurs je serai prêt en sa
compagnie admirer la collection complète
de ses tableaux bandits dont vous
l'aimez bien pauvre
ah je suis content très content au désir
salue plaisir on est content voilà j'ai
là une valise vide pour mettre tous les
jouets que sabrina veut me donner balle
à sabrina
il a pour toi françois la collection
complète de mes dessins ouah ouah